it sounds like left-brain ie conceptual
writers have a lot of trouble letting go
they're just they're so formulaic and
there's so much about you know making
sure that this makes sense and you know
whereas with these right brain people
they're just all over the place and
there's just too easily lead so it
sounds like you do exercises to help the
left brain people let go and the right
brain Pina so or another way Welton so
it's a great video that can send people
again you can email my system which is
Lisa query Manette assist neurologists
and she'll really break down the
conceptual intuitive parts of the brain
and literally what one part is good at
where the part is good at but they can't
talk to each other these because they
have a different process or it's like
the old days with PCs and Apple so like
you have a dream which is a very
intuitive experience nonlinear
non-causal but it's really evocative I
mean you try to tell someone about the
dream which is a conceptual exercise and
the best you can do is kind of like get
them to go oh I see how you had a really
interesting dream but they don't
necessarily experience it that way so
yeah it's the hardest part is turning
off your home base and then when I can
get you over to the other side I will
give you exercises because everyone
knows about the 10,000 hours to become
an expert of some people even Malcolm
Gladwell has said the 10,000 hours was
the wrong thing to focus on that there's
nothing magical about 10,000 hours
what he said was 10,000 hours of
dedicated practice everyone latches on
to 10,000 hours everyone forgets
dedicated practice dedicated practice is
way people become an expert in something
is sure they got to put a lot of time
and energy and passion into it but it's
not it's what they do what their
training is how they train and so if you
think about if you want to be I trained
at Second City improv they'll let you on
stage for a year and a half because they
are you're doing specific exercises
every day to learn certain key skill
sets that ultimately those integrates
together and then they'll put you on
stage same thing with Juilliard and
acting same thing if you're a
professional athlete it's about specific
exercises to train yourself to develop
the key skill sets and integrate and so
I and I'm sure we'll talk about the
somebody I was a working studio writer
for 11 years
and while I did that I taught once a
year at UCLA to give back and for fun
and then over the last six years I've
been building a teaching business and
teaching and working with rioters and I
have a lot of friends and a lot of
people who are very successful lighters
and almost all of them either figured
all this stuff out themselves which
takes about 10 to 12 years for most
people or they had someone help them and
usually two kinds of people that help
them a manager or they get to be a
writers assistant and staffs on a TV
show and that showrunner following that
showrunners process I know someone who
worked on Breaking Bad and working with
Vince Gilligan for three years taught
her how to change her process in fact
this is a great story she was very
intuitive and she got on to Breaking Bad
and Breaking Bad what'll happen is in
the beginning of the season Vince
Gilligan lost all the writers in the
room to come up with certain ideas and
pitched ideas and if you like the idea
he writes it on an index card and it
goes on the board and ultimately there's
all these ideas on the board that
they're going to start to work with who
developed the the season well if you're
a new writer you really want to get a
lot of ideas on the board because if
he's going around the room and then of
your ideas get on the board that doesn't
look so good
well his rule was the idea had to fit on
the card so if you start pitching an
idea and he's writing and he runs out of
room might be a great idea but he ran
out of room on the card it doesn't go on
the board and she's like I couldn't get
my ideas out concisely enough she said I
didn't know how to speak an index card
and so she had to learn and this is one
of the things I trained creative writers
to do is how to take what they see and
feel and how to communicate it in a very
concise way and so that's just one
example I'm sure she learned a million
things I'm working with someone like
Vince Gilligan but that's just one
example she learned how to be very
concise in how she thought and felt and
pitched so the way that most writers get
here is they
worked in TV for several years with a
really great showrunner and through that
process you learn these skill sets and
you adapt and you develop or you just
get pushed out or there is a manager who
will work intently with you because the
reality is most writers if not all
writers they have certain strengths
certain weaknesses and certain blind
spots blind spots are weaknesses you
don't know you have the key is to a
figure out what your blind spots are so
now that least they're known weaknesses
then how do you turn those weaknesses
into strengths that's what that
dedicated practice comes in and it's
very difficult to do this yourself so a
manager who really knows what they're
doing they will develop right over you
know bill take a ride who's really good
but not exceptional and they will train
that right over one two or three years
to do this and then when that writer can
write at that level they'll go out with
a script pretending that that was the
first thing the writer wrote by
definition when you sell something
that's the first script you ever wrote
you never talk about the rest of it so
the writers that I know who have career
especially the best careers generally
speaking either they were trained by
show runners because they were able to
work in TV early on or they were trained
by managers very few of them were self
trained it's possible I know some
examples but it took a decade and and
they're rare that they got there well
the reality is there are a lot of
writers who don't live in LA so they
can't work on the show and even if you
live in LA and you're like okay I'll
work on the show for training where do I
sign ups not that easy it's very
competitive and the thing about managers
is they're so busy servicing their
clients no one wants to do development
anymore so the manager has to really
work with they're their top writers and
really help them develop their material
they don't have time to work with their
new writers or emerging writers so as
all these writers who are like having a
manager but they won't spend a lot of
time helping me and there's always
managers saying god I really wish I
could be helping these writers but I
don't have time so it's really hard to
find someone to do that kind of training
so that's when I used to teach at UCLA
for a long time I was and someone
challenged me this like can you
a training program to train writers like
this if they don't have a managers can
do this for them if they are not yet
able to get on a TV show or they don't
want to or they don't live in LA is
there another way they can learn these
skill sets because a lot of the the
programs out there they're just telling
people to take your writing and put it
into this paradigm but so what I did is
I wanted to create a series of workshops
that could teach these new skills so
that's where this all came from
you